Una recta pasa por los puntos -1, 6
y el punto 5, -4.
¿Cuál es la ecuación de esta recta?
Así que lo primero que quiero hacer,
es graficar a esta recta y los datos que me dan.
Entonces éste es mi eje de las "x",
éste es mi eje de las yes.
Aquí tengo mi plano cartesiano.
Y el primer punto que me dan es el -1, 6,
así que vamos a dibujar, -1 en "x" y 6 en "y"...
6 para arriba.
Entonces tengo este primer punto.
Después tengo otro punto el 5, -4,
ese dato también no los dan, así que es 5 a la derecha,
5 en "x" y 4 hacia abajo,
y tengo este otro
punto de aquí.
Y ya que tengo estos dos puntos,
entonces voy a trazar la recta que pasa por ellos.
Y lo voy a intentar hacer lo mejor posi...
no, esto no es una recta...
lo mejor posible y por eso
lo voy a hacer mejor punteado.
Ya que tengo esta línea recta punteada,
ahora sí.
Para encontrar la ecuación de esta recta, me voy a fijar en que ecuación de recta quiero encontrar.
Y para esto quiero encontrar la ecuación de la recta,
"y" es igual a "mx" más b,
es decir, la ecuación de la recta
en la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen.
Y bueno, para esto, lo que me gustaría saber es
¿quién es la pendiente?
Pero la pendiente es ni más, ni menos, que
el cambio en "x" con respecto a lo que cambia en "y"
o dicho de otra manera, como la diferencia
del valor de "y"en el punto final,
menos el valor de "y"en el punto inicial
entre la diferencia
del valor de "x"en el punto final,
menos el valor de "x" en el punto inicial.
Es decir, esto es lo mismo que
el cambio de "y" en el cambio en "x"
o lo podemos ver como el alza entre el avance, es decir, el cambio horizontal entre el cambio vertical
o en dado caso,
lo podemos ver como "y2" menos "y1",
esto es el cambio en "y",
es lo que cambiamos de "y" de un punto al otro
entre "x2" menos "x1",
que esto es, ni más ni menos,
que el cambio en "x".
Es decir, lo que cambiamos en "x"
de un punto al otro.
Y bueno, pues entonces ya que tengo esta idea,
entonces puedo utilizar esta fórmula para sacar mi pendiente.
Si yo me fijo en estos dos que tengo,
¿qué es lo que voy a encontrar?
En primer lugar en el punto inicial...
y voy a suponer que éste es mi punto inicial...
éste de aquí, estaba situado en "y" igual a 6
y baje hasta "y" igual a -4.
Así que de aquí, hasta acá, podemos ver que
hay una diferencias de 10 unidades,
es decir, del punto inicial al punto final en "y",
estamos cambiando 10 unidades.
O simple y sencillamente podemos
sustituir los valores en la fórmula,
es decir, el punto final en "y" que es -4,
menos el punto inicial en "y" que es 6.
Recuerda que a éste fue al que
bautizamos como "y2",
y a éste fue al que llamamos "y1"
y entonces nos va a quedar -4, -6
lo cual son 10 unidades de diferencia,
en este caso me va a quedar -10,
y todo esto...
déjame poner, igual a -10...
y todo esto hay que dividirlo, ¿entre quién?
Bueno, entre el cambio en "x", pero
¿quién es el cambio en "x"?
pues lo que cambie en "x" desde este valor que era -1, hasta el valor de 5.
¿Cuántas unidades hay de -1 a 5?
Pues bueno, déjame graficarlo,
si yo me fijo en éste como "x1" y éste como "x2"
entonces
estoy cambiando de aquí hasta acá,
y son 6 unidades, fíjate que empezamos en -1,
caminamos una para llegar al 0 y después
5 hasta llegar al 5, son 6 unidades.
Y si aplicamos la fórmula,
pues entonces nos va a quedar,
"x2" menos "x1", es decir,
5, éste es "x2" menos -1, que es el valor de "x1",
por lo tanto, 5 menos -1
y bueno 5 menos por menos, me da más,
entonces me queda 5 más 1, lo cual es 6...
y bueno, -10/6
es lo que nos da de pendiente.
Que esto lo podemos simplificar,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que -5/3,
sacamos mitad arriba y mitad abajo.
Y perfecto, porque ya con esto encontramos la pendiente.
Ya sabemos al menos que la pendiente vale -5/3,
y entonces déjame reescribir otra vez,
esta ecuación de mi recta.
Me queda "y" es igual a -5/3 de "x" más "b".
Lo único que hice fue sustituir el valor de mi pendiente
y ahora me voy a preguntar
¿cómo puedo encontrar a "b"?
Y para eso me voy a fijar
en uno de estos puntos,
es decir, me voy a fijar
en la información que tengo.
Y voy a usar este punto,
aunque puedo usar este otro.
Sin embargo lo importante es tomarme uno de estos dos puntos
y me voy a tomar éste de aquí,
y dice,
cuando "x" vale -1, "y" vale 6, entonces
6 es igual a -5/3 por -1, es el valor de "x", más "b".
Estoy situado en este punto donde sabemos
que estamos en nuestra recta.
Entonces, pues lo único que hay que hacer
es resolver para "b",
es decir, buscar la "b" que satisfaga
esta ecuación.
Y bueno, me queda 6 es igual a -1 por 5/3,
que son 5/3 positivos, más "b".
Y para despejar a "b" lo que voy a hacer es restar -5/3
de ambos lados de la ecuación.
-5/3 por aquí, -5/3 por acá.
Y entonces, ¿qué me va a quedar?
6 menos 5/3,
¿esto cuánto es?
Bueno, voy a ponerlo por acá,
para que sea mucho más fácil resolverlo.
6 menos 5/3,
lo voy a escribir aquí arriba...
6 menos 5/3 es exactamente lo mismo
y al 6 lo voy a convertir en tercios.
6 es 18/3, menos 5/3 esto es igual a 13/3
y ya tengo mi denominador común, 13/3.
Y por lo tanto, "b" vale 13/3...
13/3 porque estos dos se cancelan
y del lado derecho solamente me queda "b".
"b" vale 13/13 y entonces ya puedo sustituir
el valor de "b" en esta ecuación que tengo aquí arriba,
"y" es igual a -5/3 de "x"...
-5/3 de "x", más "b", pero "b" es 13/3,
más 13/3.
Y bueno, esto lo podemos escribir en forma mixta,
13/3 es lo mismo que 4 1/3,
es decir, en donde cortamos al eje de las yes,
es en el punto 0, 13/3 ó 0, 4 1/3 que es éste de aquí
y además la pendiente nos dice
que tenemos -5/3.
Claramente se nota que es una recta
que va hacia abajo,
por lo tanto tenemos una pendiente negativa
y esto visto en su forma mixta, es lo mismo que 1 2/3,
es decir, que por cada cambio en "x",
hay un cambio de 1 2/3 en "y"...
por cada unidad de cambio en "x",
entonces vamos a cambiar 1 2/3 en "y" hacia abajo.
¡Y ya está! aquí tenemos la solución de este problema que espero que te haya sido bastante útil.